sex cannot be changed
every single human being is either
female or male and by the way that
applies to people who have differences
of sexual development how many women and
girls have to be hurt before our society
acknowledges that and our law makers and
our laws acknowledge that how many women
in prison have to be raped how many
teenage girls have to be subjected to
men walking around with erect penises in
bathrooms and spas before our society
comes to grips with the reality of what
is going on i consider feminism to be a
political movement to liberate women and
girls from male oppression in
contemporary society what is generally
taken to be feminism is not feminism at
all
the the movement to sort of promote the
idea that men can be women
is fundamentally anti-feminist it is
anti-woman and it is very politically
regressive
nonetheless it is often assumed that
people who promote the idea that men can
be women are actually feminists but
that's a misunderstanding everybody at
the end of the day knows that men are
male and women are female but we seem to
be in this very confused place where
some people are insisting on redefining
the word sex
to include the phrase gender identity
but nobody has really properly defined
that term my party has been pushing this
gender identity agenda in law and
throughout society and it's terrible for
women and girls
we currently have pending before
congress it's currently before the u.s
senate something called the equality act
which would completely redefine sex to
include gender identity for virtually
all purposes under u.s civil rights law
and
from my point of view that would be
devastating for women and girls the the
abolition of sex the obliteration of the
material reality of biological sex
should scare everyone there's an
evolutionary biologist by the name of
colin wright who talks about this in
terms of evolutionary biology and he
says that if we allow the notion of
biological sex to be obliterated in
society we have lost our tether to
reality and he's exactly right every
single person is either female or male
there's nothing wrong with saying that
transgender isn't real it was simply
made up to persuade people that there's
some coherent category of people for
whom sex is irrelevant that is not true
and we should not be afraid to say so
regardless of where we land on the
political aisle rank and file democrats
reach out to me all the time every day i
hear from democrats on social media and
in my email who tell me that they are
absolutely fed up with what the
democratic party is doing on this topic
and some of them say they'll never vote
democrat again some of them say that
they have unregistered with the
democratic party and re-registered as
independents i know
at least two women who voted for donald
trump last year because of this issue
these are women who despise donald trump
cannot stand him did not vote for him in
2016 but voted for him in 2020 because
of this issue democrats are furious and
if our party leadership doesn't start
listening to us they're really going to
lose votes
[Music]